Joining us
right now is
former NATO
supreme allied commander
and CNN military analyst
General Wesley Clark.
It's good to see you.
General, let's start
with kind of exactly what John and Sam
Kiley were talking about.
We have these latest
and continued
strikes day and night coming from Russia
into Ukraine.
But now we are at the same time
we're seeing more and more strikes
on Russian soil.
What does this intensity is
kind of the way
I'm kind of describing in this moment
suggest to you
about this phase of the war
Russia still doesn't
have the means to really go
after significant
Ukrainian military targets
with its missiles.
For whatever reason, it just doesn't.
And it feels
it gets better return
by simply punishing the Ukrainian people.
It's like if you're not
if you don't like me,
I'm going to kill you.
And so it's a personal attack
by the Russians on the Ukrainian people.
Iranians, on the other hand, recognize
that Belgorod is a key logistics center.
So these additional Russian forces
that are moving in around
Belgorod are actually disrupting
the ability of the Russian forces
to respond
to a potential
Ukrainian counteroffensive.
Now, where that counteroffensive is,
we don't know, could be in the mood area.
It could be in the south toward multiple
It could be in the north
northeast of Clark.
And in that case,
what happens in Belgorod
would be really significant.
The Ukrainians are not disclosing this,
and they probably haven't
even made a decision on it.
A lot of it depends.
This is a cat and mouse
game at this point.
They're doing reconnaissance in force
or using their artillery
they're looking at Russian reactions
and they're trying to assess
where their best opportunities are.
And I wanted to ask you about that.
But in terms of a best opportunity,
because we have heard
so much
about the imminent counter offensive,
and when it comes down to
if you want to call these
the final moments before it would begin.
What are the right conditions
in your view, General?
For Ukraine to launch this effort?
First of
all, you've got to
look at the environmental situation on
the ground going to support your forces.
Secondly, you've got to look at where
the Russians are,
the Russian strengths,
weaknesses, dispositions.
And third,
you've got to look at your own forces
and where they are
or they're ready
is all the equipment
there Is there more training to be done?
And then you have to put these conditions
under a plan that works.
That plan is going to involve
some deception
It's going to involve some French.
We're going to be surprised by it.
So we
and the American side,
not only the American public,
but probably the American military
don't really know
what the Ukrainians will actually do.
There have been some wargaming
or some cooperation there.
There's obviously intelligence
sharing on both sides.
But the actual command decisions,
those are going to be held
very close by Ukraine.
We are moving into the period
where the ground is drawing out.
We are getting a lot more
Western equipment
in and the training
is continuing for the Ukrainian forces.
Question is, is.
What's the Russian disposition?
Where are the weaknesses?
What about that
in place
and what mood
is that going to provide an opportunity?
Where do they stand in the south
and the Ukrainians
actually get to the Crimea land bridge
if they can?
That's decisive
because this war only ends when Mr.
Putin realizes he's going to lose.
That's why,
although the United States
is not encouraging and supporting it,
these Ukrainian attacks into Russia,
even the drones in Moscow
are strategically valuable.
They bring the fact home
to the Russian people that,
yes, there's a war.
It's not a police action.
And yes, the Ukrainians are real people
and they are going to fight back.
And you need to stop this.
So this is all part
of the strategic build.
So I think
we're going to have a very busy summer.
But we can't predict where or when.
You think
it's great to have you on, as always.
General, thank you for your time.